Welcome everybody, it's wonderful to meet
those of you that I've chatted with on
the phone and been emailing with.
I'm Amanda Greco, it's been my
pleasure to work on behalf of PMP and
engaging alumni community for this
event that's happening on October 20th.
I think I've told you all on the phone or
in some capacity that the day is starting
off with ClassNotes Live, so
you're conversations or texts and
stories that you share are going to
really set the tone for the day.
And the idea is that instead of having
everyone just show up and have to be on
a one-way receiving end of conversations
by hearing the stories that you put out
there, it will open up conversations and
start little trails of ideas that
people will follow up with you about, and
really build on as the day progresses.
So thank you for taking the time to put
a lot of thought into your idea and for
being here today to work with J D,
who I'm pleased to introduce.
J D is the Director of our Mastering
in Communication Initiative,
you can talk a little bit more
about that in just a minute.
And he's also a lecturer here
in organizational behavior.
And if you wouldn't mind,
it would be great to just go around the
table introduce yourself, share your name,
the year you graduated and what compelled
want to talk for Class Notes Live,
keeping it brief, so
that we have an idea of why you are here.
>> I'm Ernie King from the class of 1980,
took an interest in public management and
how it relates to the public
sector government.
>> I'm Jack Banning, class of '84, my wife
and I three years ago set up a non-profit
that's gotten more traction in the last
I said someone has to tell the story.
And she very nicely pushed me forward,
and so this opportunity came up and
so it was an opportunity to try it out.
>> I'm Martha Weeks and I'm actually
a communications coach here at the GSB.
Several of us are here today who
worked for JD and we were doing just
writing coaching, and now we're
getting more into speech coaching.
And so JD invited us to come
to the session tonight and
I'm just learning right now what it's all
about, so thanks for letting us be here.
>> I'm Bell Carpenter, I'm currently
serving on the Los Altos City Council
as mayor pro tem, and I'm here as I was
a class of 82 at the business school.
And I'm here to, hopefully,
inspire people to serve their local
communities in public service.
>> I'm Mary Lang, I'm [INAUDIBLE].
>> I'm [INAUDIBLE], class of '99,
I'm here because I believe
about ten years ago
co-founded a corporation
called [INAUDIBLE] foundation.
Which focuses on new ventures, nonprofit
ventures that you can capture in response.
And we thought work with them over
these early parts of their life.
>> Diego class of '03,
I started a nonprofit in math and
science early this year,
and I wanted to comment about it and
give feedback, and.
>> I'm Alice Laplante,
class of 90, across the street,
I'm also communications.
>> I'm Tory class of 2008 and
the process of starting a company,
basically, ING direct meets Cuba.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
you can do
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm Ashley Boren,
I´m of the class of `89 and I´m the
executive of a non-profit environmental
group called sustainable conservation.
And I´m here to improve my
communication skills in preparation for
the
>> Hi my name is
Call to action
[INAUDIBLE].
>> Well, I'll ask a question,
how many of you here are involved in
taking care of with the parents or
a loved one?
I'm here to talk about the aging
population, and caregiving, and
taking care of yourself, and
taking care of the families.
>> What's your name?
>> Sharon class of '83.
>> I'm Carol Siskind, I work in the office
of development, across the way,
so I'm an interloper to hear
about this program [INAUDIBLE].
>> I'm Bruce Baker, class 55, that's 1955.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
[INAUDIBLE] community resource group,
the stands were generally use per minute.
And has been an exciting two
decades that we a lot about, and
continues to be an exciting venture.
>> Thank you all for being here.
Yes, the two in the back.
>> Sorry, I'm Jenna Engleman,
I'm another one with the communication
purchase citizen that.
>> And I'm Teresa Johnson, I'm a writer
for Seattle Business Magazine.
>> So thank you very much for
all being here,
I will turn the evening over to JD and
thank you for being here.
>> Absolutely.
When I first met Caroline,
she was one of my CAT students.
CAT is the critical analytical thinking
course here at the GSB that all
first-year students
are now required to take.
So she was one of 16 students about
the group that were gathered here who
was in one of my seminars in critical and
analytical thinking.
And the way I first got to know Caroline
is she cited Stan Delaney in her paper and
said personal conversation
with Stan Delaney,
Morgan Stanley Vice President and
his GSP graduating year.
Well, I know Stan and
I was like, why is she citing somebody
that I know in her CAT paper?
She's probably figuring out
a way to get on my good side.
The first time I met her sister Catha was
in the upper r buckle on the other campus.
And as you know,
people run quickly through
upper r buckle because it's not
a place you spend a lot of time.
And as I ran through, I saw this
familiar student, I said, hey Caroline,
how are you?
And she goes, no I'm not Caroline.
I'm sorry, aren't you in my CAT class?
She goes, that's my twin sister.
I didn't know that we had both Caroline
and Catha in last year's first-year class,
they're now rising second years.
And the first time I got to know Monica
was when Monica sent me an email,
last March and she said, Professor Shrom,
I've not had you in any classes yet.
But two friends, Caroline, Catha and
I have started our own venture and
we have a real opportunity to talk
about our venture at the Ted X
conference that Stanford's hosting in May,
but we need some help.
Would you meet us and coach us?
And that began my relationship
with Caroline, Catha, and Monica,
who have founded an organization
called Farm to Cup.
And their goal is to eliminate
the intermediaries and
get rich,
rich wonderful coffee directly from
Guatemalan farms into your
cup in a very efficient,
effective, and inspiring way.
Now I worked with the three of them for
several different sessions, and
in those sessions, we Figured out
the story that they were going to tell.
We figured out what details to include and
not, how many of them should speak when
they did their short three-minute
speech at the TEDx event, and
had them all ready for their audition.
They did their video, and
they sent their video off to TEDx so
that they could be a part of
the TEDx event here at Stanford.
And they were turned down.
They weren't chosen to be a part of that.
And I was disappointed.
They were extremely disappointed.
They did get to present their coffee and
serve their coffee, but
they didn't get a moment on
the stage to talk about farm to cup.
But in August, I got an email from Caffa,
letting me know that the next morning and
I should turn on NBC News early in the day
because they were talking about
on the morning news show.
Using the coaching that I had
given them to get ready for
the event that they never got to speak at.
Right now, as we speak,
the three of them are in Guatemala,
putting together more relationships so
that they can show up next week, start
their second year as MBA students and
continue pursuing their business venture.
And they're just one of many examples of
the privilege that I get to work
with MBA students here at the GSB.
So when Amanda said, would you come in and
work with Alumni, to help them tell
their stories more effectively?
It took me about a quarter
of a second to say you bet.
I would love to have
that chance to do that.
So what we're going to do tonight,
is not presentation skills 101.
First of all,
as I listen to the introductions,
I don't think it's necessary.
And secondly, if that is something
you have a need or concern for,
I've got some resources
that I will point you do.
We're going to actually
do the advanced level.
We're going to do the second year elective
instead of the first year required class.
And we're going to look
specifically at story telling and
it's a concise storytelling.
How do I tell the story of my cause,
my venture, my start up, in a very
short amount of time that causes an impact
for the audience that I'm trying to serve?
The way I'm going to do this is I'm
going to talk for a little bit.
I've come up with no real
apologies to Stephen Covey.
Seven habits of highly
concise storytellers, and
I will give you what those habits are.
You'll also quickly know that I love
teaching with video, and I particularly
think all of the video clips I plan
to share tonight, are from Ted.
Is anybody unfamiliar with Ted?
Anybody not know?
Alice is not familiar with Ted,
okay, couple.
Ted is an amazing website, I'm going to
give you a handout in a minute that
gives you a way to start on there.
Ted.com is a great website for
seen presentations.
None of them are more than 18 minutes long
but what people don't know is that they
have a special section on their website
that's presentations under 6 minutes.
And I'm going to use
some of those clips so
that you can really see some examples
of concise powerful storytellers.
TED is a conference, it stands for
Technology, Entertainment, and
Design, and I love to just entertain
myself by watching TED Talks.
My husband wanted me to clean the garage
yesterday because we were having friends
over last night.
[LAUGH] I was like cleaning the garage.
[LAUGH] That's the job I get.
So I took my laptop down to the garage and
I turned on ted.com and
I was putting stuff away and
moving the bikes and sweeping but
I had TED Talks going in the background,
so I'm a geek, but I'm a fan of Ted.
And I will before you leave.
I'm going to not use any slides tonight.
I'm going to write
a little bit on the board.
We're going to have a conversation, but
I will give you one handout that has some
links from TED and some links from other
places hereat the GSP that I hope will
help you in preparing your story.
Also have 1, possibly 2, volunteers who
are far enough along in their prep for
the 40th anniversary event.
Then, in the second half of our time
together there actually going to
come up and do part of their story and
I’m going to coach them in front of you.
And we'll see what we can do to make
their stories more concise and stronger.
And then, we'll also figure out a way
that we're offering coaching for
alumni as they prepare for
the event on October 20th.
Is it the 20th?
And we'll figure how to make sure that
you know that that's available to you.
We are taping tonight because some
people weren't able to be here.
So if you do speak up, feel free but know
that you will be captured on audio and
that it will be made available to
other alumni who are preparing for
the same thing that you're preparing for.
So with that said,
let's move in to the conversation.
And it's interesting that we're
looking at concise storytelling.
Friday afternoon, I got to spend two or
three hours at Oracle, and
I was invited there by,
they have somebody whose job title is
head writer for
corporate cinema at Oracle.
Like, how cool of a job is that?
I hear head writer, and I think of
the Alan Brady show and Dick Van Dike, and
what he does is he writes all of
the scripts for all of the corporate video
that Oracle does to communicate to their
clients and users about the products.
Nothing more than two minutes long.
Highly technical,
a great deal of technical information, but
all in two minutes or less.
Now, he will do a series,
kind of like a serial,
where there will be different parts to it.
But they don't put a 20
minute video up online.
They'll put ten two minute videos up and
they actually can track their
effectiveness by how people click through.
And so, the whole idea as
attention spans get shorter,
as competing things on our computer
are coming at us, shorter is better.
And so, looking at concision I think is
a good place I think for us to start.
Let's start with one example from TED.
For people who are watching on the video,
we will also be providing
to you all of the links for the videos
that I show here with one exception.
One that is only available for the people
who are here in the room tonight, and
you can watch them there and everybody
you'll get this as a handout, as well.
And so, we'll start with the first one,
and let me get this up.
And we'll go to Mark Bezos.
As you watch this, see what works and
what you could do differently
to make this stronger.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
When I'm not fighting poverty,
I am fighting fires as the assistant
captain of a volunteer fire company.
Now, in our town where the volunteers
supplement a highly skilled career staff,
you have to get to the fire scene
pretty early to get in on any action.
I remember my first fire.
I was the second volunteer on the scene.
So there was a pretty good chance
that I was going to get in.
But still, it was a real foot-raise
against the other volunteers to get to
the captain in charge to find out
what are assignments would be.
When I found the captain he was
having a very engaging conversation
with the homeowner, who was surely having
one of the worst days of her life.
Here it was, the middle of the night.
She was standing outside in
the pouring rain under an umbrella,
in her pajamas, barefoot,
while her house was in flames.
The other volunteer who had arrived just
before me, let's call him Lex Luther.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Got to the captain first and
was asked to go inside and
save the homeowners dog.
The dog, I was stunned with jealousy.
Here was some lawyer or money manager
who for the rest of his life gets to
tell people that he went into a burning
building to save a living creature.
Just because he beat me by five seconds.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well, I was next.
The captain waved me over.
He said, Bezos,
I need you to go into the house.
I need you to go upstairs,
past the fire, and
I need you to get this
woman a pair of shoes.
[LAUGH] I swear.
Not exactly what I was hoping for,
but off I went.
Up the stairs, down the hall past the real
firefighters who are pretty much done
putting out the fire at this point, into
the master bedroom to get a pair of shoes.
Now, I know what you're thinking,
but I'm no hero.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I carried my payload
back down stairs where I met my nemesis
in the precious dog by the front door.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We took our treasures
outside to the homeowner where not
surprisingly his received much
more attention than did mine.
>> [LAUGH]
>> A few week later the department
received a letter from
the homeowner thanking us for
the valiant effort displayed
in saving her home.
The act of kindness she
notes above all others,
someone had even gotten
her a pair of shoes.
In both my vocation at Robinhood and my
avocation as a volunteer firefighter I am
witness to acts of generosity and
kindness on a monumental scale but
I'm also witness to acts of grace and
courage on an individual basis.
And you know what I've learned?
They all matter.
So as I look around this room at people
who either have achieved or on their way
to achieving remarkable levels of success,
I would offer this reminder, don't wait.
Don't wait until you make your
first million to make a difference
in someones life.
If you have something to give,
give it now.
Serve from the soup kitchen,
clean up a neighborhood park, be a mentor.
Not everyday is going to offer us
a chance to save somebody's life.
But everyday,
offers us an opportunity to affect one.
So get in the game.
Save the shoes.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> So,
what worked about Mark Betzos' story?
What was effective about that?
And it wasn`t even four minutes,
I think it was 3:45.
Gary?
You haven't been cold called in years.
That's why I let Bruce
off the hook on this one.
>> It's very concrete, so I wasn't
really paying attention to the story.
More of like, you can actually
see the visuals the shoot,
I can imagine it there,
having that conversation.
So that sort of grabs you
with a very concrete story
that walks you through the entire thing.
So it's a very effective in that sense.
>> Yeah, and details like the shoes,
the master bedroom,
the real firefighters,
all of those little details,
just enough that you were inside
the story, that you could see it.
Okay, what else worked, Bruce?
>> Well, a lot of his somewhat
self-deprecating style.
>> [LAUGH]
>> His style [INAUDIBLE] and
I'd try to underline the circumstances.
>> Yeah, and the safest humor we
can ever use in presentations,
particularly in storytelling,
is self-deprecating humor.
When I do humor that puts somebody else
down, either somebody in the audience,
or somebody who is not present, and
I make fun of, there's a risk in that.
When I make fun of myself,
it's usually fairly safe.
When I diminish myself, but it's safe.
What else worked about that?
Yes.
It's Ernie.
Right.
>> Ernie.
I had to generalize this one, but
I mean in this case having firefighters
here on was to grab your attention.
>> Yeah.
>> And he used it as a prop as well.
>> Yeah, the use of the prop and
then when he pulled the jacket aside,
held the helmet.
I was like, man.
I can't do that with a laser pointer.
My props just aren't as cool.
But, and the thing was,
the whole moment, you were
captivated from the minute he began.
Not appropriate for every presentation
that you do but it work well there.
Yes.
>> You are also saying there
are really amazing hero moment when
in fact the irony all the way through and
the hero moment was in the simple thing
your intention all the time was this major
story and all this amazing simple story.
>> Yeah the unexpected, and
I think we provided the Chip Heat excerpt
from Chip Heat's book Made to Stick and
in his success matrix the U stands for
unexpected.
You were expecting something huge and
it was a pair of shoes, okay?
Yes, and I'm struggling on a first name.
>> Ashley.
>> I like how he,
the closing thought of save the shoes,
that sort of closing line
that you sort of left with.
I thought that was a great
way to drive it all home.
>> Yeah.
And easy to remember and
tied to his direct message.
And your hand was also up?
>> Yeah.
It was a situation where I felt like I
wouldn't want to be in that situation, and
especially with an animal.
>> Yeah.
>> Having a pet is always
caring for your pet.
>> Yeah, so particularly for people who
are pet people, there was an emotional
tie to it that you're thinking, that would
be awful, or those who've experienced.
My sister in law, she and her family just
went through a house fire last weekend.
So as I was watching this
clip getting ready for
tonight I was like, can I do this?
I'm thinking of Kathleen and Joey.
And so there is that touch there, but
it's a touchpoint that
brings us to our audience.
Yes, and I didn't catch your first name.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yoriko?
Yoriko.
>> So
he flagged is obviously connected to this
audience he said all
you smart rich people.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah complimented them.
>> Yes.
>> It made him closer,
made him more connected to them.
>> Right.
>> Okay very good.
Do you think all of you can do
what you just saw him do when
you do your speech on October 20th?
I do.
I was expecting a little more GSP sort of,
you bad.
But the beautiful about communication
is it is part art and part science.
The part that's art, yeah,
there are some people who have
gifts that not everyone has, okay?
Take it away from presentations and
look at basketball.
Somebody who's 6"5' is automatically,
just by his height,
going to be better at basketball
than somebody who's 4"8'.
So sometimes there
are natural differences,
that's There's also the science which
means there's strategies we can learn.
There's tips and checklists and
things that each of us can
employ that work for us.
And everything we do inside of this I want
you to filter through what works for you.
It has to be authentic for you.
For you to do just like Mark Betsos did,
it would look a little phony.
But if we can find your authentic
style and what is appropriate for
you, that would that's
what we want to shoot for.
Yes Diego?
>> Yes.
So I mean so one concern is I see
that I think I have a slightly more
complex message that I am trying
to communicate than his, and
so it's a great story,
it's an incredibly simple message, and
so you look at it, and okay,
where is the tipping point?
How much can you cram into that
timeframe and still get that moment?
>> Yeah.
>> It'll be fun to explore that, but
I mean, it was a very simple
message from his story.
>> Can you make yourself yeah,
because I know in four minutes it
probably has to be pretty simple.
>> Definitely I think that this
was easier to fit into that and
I think that we often.
Chip Heat talks about
the curse of knowledge.
We know so much about our idea and
so much about our startup.
Somebody asks us what time it is, and
we tell them how to build a clock.
It's like, no.
What is the piece that is at the core?
That is necessary?
So we can work on that a little bit.
And I would encourage you to spend some
time, either on Ted or other places,
looking at people who have
similar stories to your own.
That are complicated but
that they simplify down.
Martha.
>> What would you advise him to do better?
>> I thought he was pretty good myself.
[LAUGH].
What, there were a few places where he
could have done a little more detail,
like slightly more.
I think there was some humor moments lost.
Had he mentioned, and I'm going to
mispronounce it, Manola Blancs?
>> Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
>> The actual brand,
like there would have been a little,
you know?
Had he given us the name of the dog,
a few places like that.
And I think he could have near
the end maybe softened the tone.
To where the tone actually let
his meaning come through more,
less of a theatrical performance and
more of a moment there.
But I think this is very sharp.
Did you have a thought?
Yes?
>> I just
thought he could have created
a more sympathy for the woman.
I mean the whole point is that she,
he said she's having
the worst day of her life.
But the fact that the thing he did
which he thought was sort of silly,
he wanted a big grand gesture and he did
something that he thought was silly and
then it made her day.
It could've been more ta da.
And the letter she wrote,
he could have actually read it, you know?
>> Hm, that's interesting
>> Extraordinary efforts of the,
he sort of like glossed over
that really quickly, but
there was a whole lot of detail about
other things, about how he feels?
So I don't know.
>> Mary?
>> I would have agreed,
I would say that he could have
made the woman at the heart of it.
>> Right.
More than himself.
>> Yeah.
>> She could have been the focus
because he was the focus.
>> Yeah.
>> Of that and you didn't know her name.
She was a anonymous letter writer.
>> The firemen are swirling around her and
they're helping her with this.
>> That's a good point yeah.
>> And
they're putting the blankets over her.
>> And then Jennifer wrote me a letter.
>> Right and he doesn't even know
that she noticing him right?
But when it comes down to it,
she did notice.
>> Good point.
I'm going to put the screen up for
a minute here.
And I have, as I mentioned earlier,
I want to keep the conversation going, but
I was needs a little bit of
framework to look at here.
I chose not to do PowerPoint slides,
I feel like sometimes we kind of have
death by PowerPoint, bullet slide
after bullet slide after bullet slide.
So I can certainly send these
seven points out by email,
I'm glad to share the notes
that I worked from but
feel free to write these down as well
if that helps you in your memory.
These are what I'm going to call the seven
habits of concise storytellers.
The first one parachute in.
There's a great book which
I will mention later.
Actually, I'm going to share-
Feel free to glance at this as I speak,
called Leadership Presence.
We brought the folks in from
the aerial group who created this.
It's great strategies around how
do I as a leader present myself?
How do I create a stage
presence as a leader?
And one of the things that they talk about
in there is start the story in the middle.
Many times, we feel like we've
got to do a lot of prefacing.
I've gotta give you all this background,
I've gotta give you all this information.
And really if we can figure out
a way to start in the middle and
then let people catch up to us, okay?
So to parachute in with very
little prefacing when Amanda and
I were planning this session and we were
deciding how we wanted to begin, I said,
you know what, Amanda,
I'd rather you do the introductions, and
you do that whole conversation.
So that I can actually start with a story,
and
I can start right in with the story,
without any prefacing.
I think even with the story I told
about Caroline, Catha, and Monica,
I could have started more in the middle,
but I wanted to have a linear progression.
So think about your story for
the 20th, how do I parachute in.
How do I not give too much background.
Four minutes goes fast.
If you spend a minute and a half or
two minutes in background,
you've lost that opportunity.
Second is select your
first words carefully.
I would also add final words.
What were his final words?
>> Save the shoes.
The coaches were in the room.
We watched a video last week together.
I think we watched it together.
The Congressman?
Do you remember his final words?
Two words, get right.
He did a short TED talk about how to
write to your elected officials and
he ended it, get writing.
So think about the last words.
What were my first words tonight?
I first met.
>> Say it again, Diego.
>> I first met.
>> Yeah.
I first met Caroline in my CAP course.
I could have begun with a lot of
things but in those seven words,
I wanted to give to you
a lot of information.
I wanted to bring into effect
my relationship with students,
I wanted to talk about
a current first year student,
I wanted to give you her name so
there's a little bit of a detail there and
I wanted to tie it into a piece of
the curriculum here at the GSP.
So I had a lot that was going
on just in those few words.
As you look at Mark Betso's clip.
I have something from [INAUDIBLE].
We're going to come to
that one in just a minute.
What were his first words?
Do you remember?
>> Fire them.
>> [LAUGH] Close.
I actually may have to
watch it again to see.
But I think it was as a volunteer fireman,
you want to get there first.
It was something along those lines.
because he was talking about
the race between him and
the other guy to get
the assignment there first.
I've not watched his clip
enough to have it memorized.
But think about your own first words.
What are the worst first words that
you can use in a presentation?
>> [LAUGH] My name's JD.
>> [LAUGH] Particularly if you're
name's not JD, really bad choice.
That.
>> What I'd like to talk to you about.
>> Hi I'm here to talk to you about.
Hi my name is JD I'm here today because,
and what happens is particularly in
professional settings there's a slide
that says JD Schrum behind you, there's
an introducer who says today we have with
us JD Schrum and then I get up and say.
Hi my name is JD Schrum.
Use those first words valuable and
think about and
maybe you want to say them multiple times,
maybe they become like a mantra or
a chorus inside of your presentation,
but think them through.
With my students that I lead during
orientations and introductions to,
I often begin with this phrase.
I believe you can achieve
mastery at anything you set your
mind to in the next two years
while you're here at the GSB.
And then I go into defining what mastery
means, what two years looks like,
and how they can achieve it.
So thinking through, first words.
Question.
>> Yes, please.
And is it Val or Belle?
>> Val or Valerie or-
>> Val, okay, I had a 50/50 chance.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yes, Val.
>> So will we be introduced so
we don't need to introduce
ourself in this four minutes?
>> It says to be determined.
I will let you know.
I'm not sure exactly.
>> Okay, because if nobody introduces us,
I'm going to say, I'm Val Carpenter,
mayor pro tem the city of Los Altos,
and then go into my speech.
>> So
you might think about it a little bit.
You could actually begin with
a little bit of the story.
A voter came to me, and she was so
incredibly upset because of da, da, da.
I'm Val Carpenter,
I'm the mayor of, and this is what.
So you may be able to
just flip it barely and
still start with something
that catches them off guard.
And we'll find out logistically
what it looks like.
The other piece,
when you're in other settings,
we often print the whole bio
of somebody in the program.
Or it's sent out in the invitation,
it's available on the website, and
then the person who does the introduction
just reads what we already.
What a waste of an opportunity.
If you're doing an introduction
somewhere other than in the PnP thing,
find out something that's
not in the printed bio.
Find a story, find an anecdote, find
something that lets you actually serve
the purpose, not just read what we read
while we were waiting for you to begin.
Okay, third one, follow Goldilocks.
Anybody with children remember, anybody
remember what the Goldilocks theory is?
Jenna, you gotta have a shot at this.
You've got three of them at home.
>> Try a lot of different things
til you find the one that fits?
>> Close, very close.
Because every part of the Goldilocks
story, there's something that's too hard,
there's something that's too soft,
there's something that's just right.
Something that's too big, something that's
too small, something that's just right.
When we look at details in our story,
we want to have just
the right amount of details.
Had Mark gone on and on and
on about the color of the truck and
the address and the street,
it would have ruined it for us.
And where we felt there was
just a little bit of a gap,
we would've liked maybe a detail or
two more.
And that's really a nuance that
you have to, how much do I share,
how little do I share in
terms of the details?
And thinking through, what are enough
details that it's illustrative,
but not so many that I bored people?
The fourth one, and
I thought Mark did this very well,
practice one person, one thought.
And particularly on the day
of the event in October,
there'll be a camera in the room,
like there is right now in the room here.
But you're not speaking to the camera,
you're having a conversation
with individuals.
And what you want to be able to do
is deliver one complete thought to
one person, kind of have that moment.
And then deliver another complete
thought to another person,
actually have that moment, and
then another thought somewhere else.
There's a place, and if you watch
Mark's video again on your own at home,
there's a place where he's
talking about different
things that you can do
that are small steps.
And he delivers one to one
third of the audience,
one to another third of the audience,
one to another third of the audience.
You can tell he's connecting
with sections of the room,
not just scattering across everywhere.
Or not just having one
conversation with one person and
leaving everybody else out in the loop,
but actually practicing that eye contact.
Eye contact is gold in storytelling.
And the more that you're actually able to
connect and pierce into somebody's eyes,
the more that you bring
down that resistance and
the more you can make that connection.
The fifth one,
this'll take a little bit of,
this'll take a little bit of work here.
Remember the magic grain truck.
So I grew up in Kansas,
and my high school English
teacher David Westling was
one of my best educators.
And he used to tell us, now,
I grew up in Hayes, Kansas, and
all the kids in my high school freshman
English class were primarily farm boys.
I was not, I was a city kid,
if you can call a city 13,000.
But we all knew what a grain truck was.
When we harvested in June,
the grain truck came, and
they dumped all of the wheat out of
the truck into the grain elevator.
And that was what the farmer got paid.
How much wheat was in the truck, and
what was the water content of
the wheat that was in the truck?
How valuable was the wheat
that was in the truck?
Mr. Westling said,
poetry is like a magic wheat truck.
If there was a way to get
12 truckloads of wheat
in one truck, how valuable would that be?
We're like, wow,
that would be pretty amazing.
You'd only make 1 trip,
instead of 12, from the farm,
and you'd make all that much money.
He said, that's what poetry is.
It's the chance to put that much
more weight into a few number of
words that they carry
that much more meaning.
Now, I'm not asking that
you become Shakespeare.
But think through,
is there word choices you can
use that carry more of a impact
then a whole bunch of words?
For example, in Mark Bezos' talk,
what did he call the other fireman?
>> Lex Luthor.
>> Lex Luthor, two words.
What does all of that conjure
up when he says Lex Luthor?
>> The bad guy.
>> The bad guy, manipulative, one time,
he later used the word, my nemesis, okay?
All of that comes through by
calling the fireman Lex Luthor.
>> But funny and cartoonish,
not calling him Hitler or somebody.
>> Exactly, exactly,
that would have only been one word.
But that would have, man, a whole
different characterization out of that.
>> [CROSSTALK] Look like Lex Luthor.
>> A little bit, he did.
>> [LAUGH] And so you want to be,
and you also have to be careful.
Like in some audiences,
Lex Luthor would mean nothing.
I was teaching undergrads last year, and I
was trying to explain the term, I think I
told this to the coaches last week, I was
trying to explain the term philistine.
Somebody was being a real
philistine about something.
I said, like Archie Bunker.
No clue who I was talking about,
none whatsoever.
And I said, like Homer Simpson.
Yeah, now we know what
you're talking about.
So you have to be careful about that,
but think about,
is there some poetry I can use,
is there some imagery?
Or maybe there's an analogy,
maybe there is a visual image.
We talked earlier, Jack, about,
you've got some visual images in your.
Sometimes a picture is worth 1,000 words.
I can put one thing up, and
it conveys a great deal of meaning.
So think about what you can do in your
four minutes that lets you get more out of
a word or more out of a slide
than just one word or one image.
Anybody a musician in here?
Yuri, is it?
>> Yeah.
>> Am I pronouncing that right?
What do you play?
>> Guitar, French horn, saxophone.
>> Kind of a slacker?
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Do you read sheet music?
>> I do on saxophone.
>> Okay, and
what is a rest in sheet music?
What does that indicate?
>> A pause in the music.
So
for a certain amount of time, basically,
you measure it out and you stop playing.
>> And when somebody composes a piece
of music, they decide in that moment,
Urie should stop playing the saxophone.
The silence is going to actually
be written into the composition.
It's especially powerful when you
see an entire symphony go silent for
a moment, because the composer
has decided that is the time
where the music is that's
represented by no notes at all,
and so for us,
the sixth strategy is too use silence.
We can use silence to let
people catch up to us,
we can use silence to frame something,
like the first time we use a phrase,
or an acronym, we may say here at the GSP.
I may need to frame it a little bit.
Or I can just use it, because it allows
me to get everyone's attention again.
Those who are my age, or older may
remember an old TV commercial where
they said, if you want to get
somebody's attention, whisper.
Want to get somebody's attention in
a class, or in a presentation, be silent.
Why did they stop talking?
What's going on?
What do I need to pay attention to now?
And just a few seconds of silence,
appropriately used,
can add emphasis to your presentation.
And the seventh strategy that I'm
going to ask you to do is know your AIM
that's an acronym that we use.
Actually, I've got enough
people here that maybe.
Anybody have Mary Munter when
you were here at school?
So, this is something
Mary Munter came up with.
Mary Munter taught
communication here at the GSP.
She'd been to the top school at Dartmouth,
and she is one of my mentors, and
I use several of her
books in my teachings.
And it stands for
audience intent and message.
Who's my audience?
What do I want them to do as
a result of this communication,
what's my intent, what's my objective?
And then how do I frame
my message in that way.
Getting back to Diego's question, you got
a lot of complicated information about.
That you want to be able to share about
your entity, about your enterprise,
about your start up.
With a certain audience,
you may share this information.
With investors, with partners,
it may be this information.
So, we decide based on who
our audience is what we want
them to do with that information,
how much we share.
The best thing to happen, now this isn't
a part of the PMP formats of fame,
the best thing to happen, especially for
entrepreneurs, and non-profit leaders,
and people who are involved in
causes is to share a little bit, and
have them ask to hear more.
And share a little bit and
You've been at one of those cocktail
parties here in Silicon Valley
where somebody says, let me tell you about
my start up, and they launch onto you, and
they just keep going, you're trying to get
to the bar, trying to get away from them?
As opposed to hooking them and
saying enough that they want to
engage in a conversation with you.
So, knowing your audience, and what do
you want them to do with the information.
Now, can we take a moment here, and
is this appropriate to talk about
the two possible branches that
their presentations make away?
Can you explain that better than I can?
>> Sure, so I think,
where all of you volunteer to be speakers,
at the time we were aiming for 18 people,
and imagine we would have everyone
in the London room with a consolidated
audience, maybe about 100, 150.
We weren't really sure what to expect,
because this is the first time in the day
where we pulled together
the fellow my community this way.
Since then we have had almost 40
people come forward with interest, and
we actually had to shut off the accepting
of new people that you know in the spirit
of really wanting to represent alumni
we haven't heard from in a long time.
Not just those who are really
piped into the JC community.
And folks who have a variety of stories,
we're going to try and
accommodate about 40 people,
and do two simultaneous rooms.
We're figuring out exactly how it's going,
maybe where we all start together,
listen to a number of introductory talks,
and
then there becomes a side room
where others are available.
They may both be kind of 50,
50 splits, but the theme that seems to be
emerging is that some of you did come into
this wanting to talk about the
organization, and I originally had posted.
To please pick out a pitch.
Make this more so about yourself.
And it seems that there's
kind of a natural interest
of some people to make a little
bit more of an explicit pitch.
Whether it be for investors, or
just action, or engagement, or volunteers.
And so, that's what we're looking at
is that there may be actually, for
some of you who want to make a little bit
more of an explicit ask of some form,
a place to do that, whereas others
might have a little bit more of
a kind of reflective story of impact.
So, regardless,
these tools are useful to you.
And this is something that as we're
finalizing the list of speakers,
I'll be getting back to you about.
If, as you hear this, you feel strongly
that you belong in one place, or
the other, and you don't think it's
self evident, please let me know.
But, if you have questions,
I'm happy to answer them.
>> I have a question.
So, will you announce what these
two categories of rooms are so
the audience can choose which
group they want to go to?
>> Yes, and there will be signage with
the program of the topic, saying,
this is the schedule.
Say, three to five what the schedule for
class outside,
neither of two room options for
that period of time.
And it kind of guides what's in
that space by the amount of area,
or if it ends up being this pitch,
maybe we all start in one space.
And then there is a reception,
or a break, and
those who want to hear the more explicit
pitches are rushed to another space.
And it would either be in the program,
or announced.
In advance and then we sign and share, and
that helps everybody know where we went.
>> Just a little confused
about what to talk about.
I don't want to pitch anything,
but I also, I mean,
it was the original point to just show
different perspectives of folks who
went through the P&P, and
how they now are reflecting.
Years later on their various interactions
with the public environment, or-
>> You know,
in your case, we talked a little
bit about you having this kind of
large kind of view from the top of social
innovation as this emerging theme, and
kind of the feel of
social entrepreneurship.
So, I still think it makes sense for
you and
Ann to probably to kind
of share your wisdom.
In more of the interact pitch, but
we can talk about that a little bit
more as you two talk to each other.
She's a colleague who is also at UCLM
that will be talking as well and
kind of pair that together.
So, we can explore that and
see what feels the most exciting to you.
But I think,
that working with a fellow alumni
would be a neat facet to your story.
And I'm the fact that you engaged
other students in the work of your
[INAUDIBLE]
>> And
as we look at the intent, whether you're
in the first room, or the second room,
or you find yourself in another setting
where you're talking about the things that
you're up to, it's that measurement
of by sharing this information,
what do I want the audience to do with it?
And sometimes, it's very explicit, that I
want to engage people as volunteers into
my organization, or
as donors into my organization.
Sometimes, it's more that I
want them to embrace the idea,
or I want them to continue
the conversation, or
I want them to reach out to somebody else,
and re-share this information.
So, it's thinking that through, what do
I want people to do as a result of it?
We had Nancy Duarte speak here at the GSB
last year, and she talked about that
she believes in business there is no such
thing as an informative presentation.
Everything at some level is persuasive.
Me spending these two hours with you,
I want you to deploy these tactics
when you deliver your presentation.
I'm not just giving you information,
I want you to practice it.
I want you to do it.
And so thinking through,
what is it that I can get people to
do as a result of this information?
So those are my seven habits of
highly concise storytellers,
but I thought a lot about
the experience of being alumni.
And I think it's great for you to be able
to come back to the GSB and hear from
a faculty member, a distinguished and
and well-regarded faculty member.
>> [LAUGH].
>> None of them were available tonight and
so I was able to come.
But I thought what was actually
more useful would be for
you to be able to hear from students.
Because often when you're back,
you may get to interact with students.
But it's rare that you
get to go to a class.
It's rare that you actually get more than
kind of networking sorts of conversations
with our students.
So I've brought some of our students
into the workshop this evening
to talk to you about their
experience in storytelling.
And what will happen is you will
see some of my students on,
let's see, I need the screen down,
that's the lower arrow.
In the class that I teach here at the GSB
called Strategic Communication, and
actually Mary is starting to
teach Strategic Communication,
next Monday is the first
class with her students.
We do a final project that students
do a 10 to 15 minute presentation
to their peers,
about a specific communications topic.
And they deliver it in class, but
then we take the best of those lessons and
we put them up on the web
as a virtual library for
other students to learn
from on their tactics.
And I had a group of students two years
ago who did one on effective story
telling.
So I'm going to show you just three
minutes of their advice to us on
storytelling.
You may not be able to see their slides as
well as I wish you could, but when I send
you the link out, you'll be able to both
watch the video and download their slides.
So let's see what our GSB students
tell us about storytelling.
>> To give you a preview
of where we're going,
we're first going to walk you through
the basics of building a story.
So what is the story?
What's the structure of a story?
How can it differ?
And what are some tips and
best practices that you employ next
time you wanted to build a story?
Next I'll show you an exercise,
where we're all going to take a chance
at writing our own mini stories.
We're then going to give you some
specific tools that you can use,
some stories that you can put in your back
pocket next time you want to actually pull
a storytelling presentation.
>> All right, so, I'm going to talk to you
guys today about how we build a story,
what do you think about
when you tell a story?
So, telling a story and giving
a presentation happen to be very similar.
You're going to have an introduction,
a middle and a conclusion.
Now there are a few things
that are different however.
In a presentation, you're going to tell
people what you're going to tell them,
tell them and
then tell them what you just told them.
In a story, you're going to have
three different distinct components,
and they're each going to
have a different goal.
So we'll start with your introduction.
Similar to a presentation, your
introduction is going to be short, and
you're going to want to drop
audience directly into the action,
really important.
There are two other objectives that
you're going to want to have for
your introduction.
The first, this is where you
establish background information.
You give the audience the information
they're going to need in the context for
understanding where the story's going.
You're also going to establish
the dramatic question.
The dramatic question is what does
the protagonist want, what is his or
her goals that they're striving
towards during the story?
Next is the middle component of the story.
In the middle component,
you have three other objectives.
Firstly, you're going to
develop the characters and
the situation that you previously
introduced in the beginning of your story.
Next, you want your major action to
happen in this part of the story.
And lastly,
you're going to introduce obstacles.
And you want a bunch of obstacles, and you
want them to be increasingly difficult,
that the protagonist needs to bump into
again and again trying to get to his or
her goal.
Lastly, you're going to have a conclusion.
Now this conclusion is going to be
the shortest part of your story, but
the most critical.
Ideally you want the last act
of the conclusion to give
the audience the most enjoyment
in the climax in what happens.
You're going to follow a three
C pattern in your conclusion,
crisis, climax, and consequences.
The crisis is the point of the most
tension, that's going to happen here.
The climax is when the crisis point
ends and the tension is released.
This is where the audience gets
the answer to the dramatic question.
Lastly you’re going to allude
to the consequences that come as
a result of this.
Now, stories mostly have this template but
they can have very many different shapes.
For instance here's Casablanca.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The story is a bit wonky but
always upward sloping to the end.
And
here's James Bond, boom pow at the
beginning, then it's boring, slowly but
surely he gets the girl.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or you could have Jurassic Park.
In which, you have a series of crises
that need to be resolved.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All right, so now you have-
>> Okay, so I liked the way that they used
movies as a way to look at
the template for stories.
And the part of the information that
they used in their 12 minute class
on storytelling is drawn from Jennifer
Acker's class that she teaches here,
actually right now during September
session on how to tell a story.
And so some of the tips and
some of the strategies that are in there
are things that they drew from her class
and then built into ths presentation.
And I will give you the link
that you can watch all of that,
as well some other student presentations.
But that short one particularly on
storytelling I think is useful,
but what I liked about it is the sense
of obstacle, climax, and consequence.
And as you think about your journey,
whether it is as an entrepreneur,
as an elected official,
as somebody who's starting an entry,
what are the obstacles
that you have overcome?
How did you overcome them?
And where are you at now as a resolution?
Now, I want you to also vary that.
If all of you go out and do the exact same
format, by the time we get to the end of
two hours of those presentations
it will be kind of dull.
There's another resource that I
will encourage you to look at and
some of you have heard me
mention her name earlier,
Nancy Duarte who's the author
of Resonate and also Slideology.
She's here in the valley, she comes and
spends a lot time here at the GSB with us,
working with our students.
She's the woman that did the PowerPoint
slides for Inconvenient Truth.
So she's the only one who's ever
gotten an Oscar for PowerPoint slides.
And in Resonate, she talks about that
every presentation follows this,
sorry folks on the video,
you're not going to get this as well,
but every story has where things begin,
they get better and then how things are.
How they could be, how they are,
how they could be, how they are.
And in the book Resonate,
she Looks at everything from Martin
Luther King's I Have a Dream Speech.
This is the way things are,
this is the way they could be,
this is the way things are,
this is the way they could be.
[LAUGH] To Steve Jobs'
introduction of the iPhone.
[LAUGH] This is the way things are,
this is the way they could be,
this is the way things are,
this is the way they could be.
And that sense of climax,
that sense of obstacle and
resolution, is a major
part of storytelling.
And this book in particular,
I think, is wonderful about,
how do you tell a story
through a presentation?
Her first book, Slidology, is more about
how do you make the visuals look good,
this is how do you make sure
the story under it is effective.
We are exactly where I
wanted to be at 8 o'clock.
Jack, are you ready for
where we wanted to be at 8 o'clock?
>> [LAUGH] I guess I am.
>> Okay,
Jack is far enough along in his prep.
You want to give me the disk and
I can get it keyed up here?
Jack is far enough along in his prep that
he said he's willing to do part of his
presentation and
get a little bit of feedback from me.
Some coaching in terms of what could
go differently, what's working,
what could go differently.
We don't expect that you will
have incorporated everything that
we have just talked about here.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But what this is great to do
is just to be able to have a dry run and
an audience that's a friendly audience.
>> So, according to E.O. Wilson,
today's species are disappearing thousands
of times faster than any time in history.
And this loss is projected to increase
to 10,000 times faster by the year 2050.
Forest loss is biodiversity loss.
Humans are responsible for
this, that means you and me.
We hope our story inspires and
engages you to stop this now.
Do two things at once.
Ten years ago, on a visit to
Kangaroo Island, South Australia, Hillary,
my wife, and I fell in love with the
native black swans and the unique ecology.
There we found an old neglected sheep and
cattle farm, Signet Park.
This is an arial of the park of
the farm when we first bought it.
All of the ground you see was
once a diverse forest ecology
along a beautiful river.
All we could imagine was grapes and
olives as far as the eye could see.
>> [LAUGH]
>> While driving the property,
we found 15 acres of land that was
dead by commercial fertilizer buildup.
Was there a solution?
Locals saw this destruction
as unavoidable farming.
University scientists helped and
three years later,
the 15 acres had tall grass and
a living ecology was again possible.
It was our revelation
to species extinction.
So we did the unthinkable to our
friends back in California, and
expanded our estimation to 800 acres and
fundamentally changed our
passion from wine and olive oil to
investing in fighting for biodiversity.
Our land allowed us to uncover the
mysteries of native plant germination and
cultivation that quickly attracted
hundreds of people who shared our passion.
No one will miss more bottles of wine and
olive oil.
But we'll all regret not helping
stop this mass extinction.
Our efforts spread, word spread, and
the Australian non-profit Biolar was
born with encouragement of our friend,
Steve Snyder and his wife of the Wood
Institute, at Stanford, or course.
With Biolar, we focused on reimagine,
restore, and reinvent biodiversity.
And new processes for finding and
germinating native seeds.
Our burning experiments germinated
native seeds long thought extinct.
More fields were prepared,
experiments expanded, and
we continue to bio reverse
the extinction trend.
Surprisingly, we became
the weed control experts.
Our farm manager made
Signet Park his PhD thesis and
data gathering efforts exploded
in intensity and scale.
Annually 450 to 650 volunteers from
six months old to 78 years old,
from 20 plus countries join
our planting festivals.
Our first summer fellow was Robin Pam,
a Stanford grad.
This year we had 100,000 seedlings for
a total of 750,000
plantings since we started.
In year one,
our goal was 5,000 trees in our lifetime.
We scaled further.
Biodiversity warriors gathered and
planted, got muddy and dialed some more.
The trees and understory grew.
We never missed the grapes or olives,
but we celebrate with both every year.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Signet Park is 10 years into
a 300 year path of biodiversity.
100 experiments in seed germination,
five plants thought long extinct.
50 experiments on weed control have
helped us to continue to reimagine
new ways to slow extinction.
The glossy black cockatoo is one of
the most endangered birds in the world.
It eats only one seed,
in one species of tree,
in one location that is disappearing
rapidly on Kangaroo Island.
We have doubled the nesting pairs
to eight, fighting back extinction.
We want Bioar to bio replicate our passion
for partnering with others in Australia
and the rest of the world
to restore habitats and
save other animals like the glossy black.
So get involved in understanding and
reinvesting in biodiversity.
We've learned that success comes
from small things that at first
seem unimportant.
And then by thought and
commitment, become the big things
that really do change the world.
And in our case, that's one seed and
one volunteer at a time.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ken,
did you begin new right when he started?
Can you tell me the time we're at,
because I didn't run my stop watch?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Just now?
>> Okay.
>> I think it's a little
over four minutes.
>> Yeah, it felt like a little bit long.
Did somebody time it?
>> Four minutes 30.
>> Okay, just barely over,
4 minutes and 30 seconds.
Myself in the hall and it's 3 minutes and
50 seconds, but I know I was slowing down.
>> Good, excellent, excellent.
So what worked well about what Jack did?
Offer him some,
this is the old plus deltas,
what worked well,
what could go differently.
We'll start off with the compliments.
What went well?
Jenny?
>> It was very personal to
hear your personal story and
the baby carriage photo was great.
>> Priceless.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah great, yes.
>> I liked the photos,
I thought that was great.
I think your tagline,
save a seed or something,
save a seed, save [INAUDIBLE]
>> One seed one volunteer at a time?
>> Yeah, one seed one volunteer at a time,
I thought that was really.
>> Yeah that was a really good place
to end in terms of word choice.
It might be more memorable if
we hear it more than once.
And so sometimes we want our
tagline to be like a punchline that
we only get if there was.
>> [CROSSTALK] Save a seed save the world?
Sorry, I'm [CROSSTALK]
>> No, I like it!
>> [LAUGH]
>> Save a seed one volunteer at a time,
then it's like I'm missing the so what.
>> Okay good good,
other things that worked well, yes?
>> I like how you came
back to the [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah.
>> Find a really nice connector for
that story.
>> Yeah.
>> And
that was the big thing a lot of our
California friends thought we were
crazy because they were expecting
lots of wine and olive oil.
>> Yeah, so and the other piece I liked
about what Ashley mentioned is that
was a little bit of an obstacle.
We came here to do this, but
there is this bigger need out here and so
we saw a little bit of the climax back and
forth in the story.
Yes?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> And, what's left yet to do?
And the line, we are 10 years
in to a 300 year experiment.
Wow, that's, you get the audacity of
what it is that you're up to, Jack.
Very well chosen language,
as we look at some of the lines,
the people are remembering.
You've worked a lot in terms of
the scripting of that, the poetry,
if you will, of that.
Yes, Diego?
>> Discussing the specific
species helped a lot in.
because when it's just that was okay,
great.
But by actually discussing
a specific personal
story of a species that really does
rely on that part of the biodiversity.
>> The hard part for me was the thing that
was actually the most interesting thing is
finding plants that no one's seen for
over 80 years.
But when I say it's the blah, blah,
blah, California, no one cares.
But as soon as you say uuuu and
you see an animal, everybody loves that.
>> Yeah.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> [INAUDIBLE] true though.
And everybody loves this [INAUDIBLE].
>> Cockatoo?
>> Was so
compelling that if you had a better photo,
that tells your entire story to start
with, as opposed to starting with.
>> Good point.
>> To start with that and say, this one
bird eats one seed from one tree and
in order to get that,
we have to improve you're already
telling your story, but lead into it.
>> More concise.
Diego?
>> You realize the focus on the planting,
you could do something personal with that,
or
you could find some artifact made out of
some fact that is no longer available
saying this hasn't been able to be made
for so long, because of the lack of this.
And suddenly, I care about that plant,
it's not just some random weed that-
>> Yeah.
>> Or animals.
>> Pull out of my garden, anyway.
>> A couple other things that
I just want to emphasize and
we'll look at how we could tweak this.
It's already very solid but our
committment is to help you make it better.
He used some phrases like surprisingly,
did the unthinkable,
and it brought up that sense of
the enormity of the task that you and
your wife are committed to and
what you're doing.
Also ended with a clear call to action.
It wasn't as overt as a volunteer,
write a check, but it was get involved.
And I thought that that was
really useful in terms of that.
What do you,
in the spirit of supporting Jack,
what do you think he could
have done differently?
We already got a few points in
terms of some of the language.
Anything else you would encourage
him to look at between now and
the 20th of October?
Diego?
>> I felt that there were times he could
have tightened up the expandedness of
what you're doing.
You used a lot of words and statistics,
but if you could just synthesize
that in one or two, the size of this
something that really just drives it home,
but isn't just numbers.
Some facts that make it more,
that kind of synthesize it better,
that would've had more power
than just regurgitating facts.
There was parts of it,
I felt it was just regurgitation himself,
but something more tangible would
have given them more power.
>> Is there something you can think
of that for you was compelling,
in terms of the statistics, Jack?
>> Just the sheer number of
experiments we had where,
what got the Wind Institute
interested in us,
was that we had a meeting with the
Institute where seven of the nine people
on the board have all been on our farm
in the last year, I didn`t know that.
And so-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Kangeron is the canary for
Australia which is the canary for
the rest of the world because it's a rock.
So close biodiversity stuff a lot of
that's happening so trying to figure out
how to make an image around those
numbers that's an interesting struggle.
>> And it's really interesting
what you just said that,
the Island is the canary for Australia,
that's an image right there
that works really well.
>> So that's the [INAUDIBLE] right?
I mean imagine a world
where it's all devastated,
now imagine this island which
is a precursor to the others,
we can actually fix this and
this is how you do it.
>> And
when you're using the phrase canary,
you're referring to the canary and
the mind, right, okay.
There also is the Canary Islands and I
got just a little lost for a second here.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Canaries and
parakeets on this island [INAUDIBLE].
>> [LAUGH] But possibly a visual,
I love the photos.
But possibly a visual that's the map
that lets you tell that story that
this is the canary to Australia, which-
>> So
the graph showing the extinction
rate isn't that compelling.
>> I like that idea starting with the-
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> People gaze over and then it's also,
why do I care about biodiversity?
>> Yeah.
>> I mean you showed me that number but
it doesn't, how does that relate to me?
>> Yeah, okay, yes?
>> I liked the initial shot of
the land with it being barren.
I'm wondering if you can
get a shot of it now.
>> I mean, in the original is 25, again-
>> So four minutes.
>> It's 4 1/2, end up being like 20
minutes, and they keep hacking away.
And I first,I didn't mention my wife said,
you have to mention me.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, no.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> We have another picture that shows,
in 300 years, it will be all green, but
right now it just shows all the rows and
all the plants [INAUDIBLE].
So it's actually, visually intensive.
>> Yeah, good.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> Go ahead, Carrol.
>> [INAUDIBLE] compared to
the point about the statistics.
I've been wondering if you can use
some silence because I think there's
a lot of power in the information but
you were going really fast and
I kind of wanted you to slow down a little
bit so I could absorb some of that, so
I think, you [INAUDIBLE].
>> I agree.
I was a little nervous.
[INAUDIBLE] put my hands to it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, and
what we're going to do in a minute here
is just have you go off script and
have you do some of that beginning again,
without needing to hold the laptop.
And I'll advance the slides for
you, so you can practice some of
that in that particular moment.
And one of the strategies along that
line that I want to work with you on.
If you're comfortable doing movement,
a great
strategy at the beginning is to take
one or two steps toward your audience.
So when I began this afternoon, or
earlier this evening, I began by,
Caroline was in my cat class
the first time I met her.
And I actually took a couple of steps, and
even though Val and I weren't connected
yet, I chose to connect with Val and
walk towards her in that moment.
If that's something,
once you're off script,
that you're comfortable doing,
the subtext is I'm bringing you something,
I have a message for you and
a gift that I'm bringing to you.
Even in a situation where you can't move.
Sometimes you're delivering
a presentation and you're behind a podium.
And you're mic and
you have to be there, Even to just begin
and take a moment into the audience
that lets you connect with them or
in a business meeting to lean forward
in your chair if you make a point.
All of that is kind of
the non-verbal communication of
I'm bringing something to you.
And I think we can work on that a little
bit at the very top in terms of
connecting with your audience.
And then the other place I'd like to
work non-verbally, if we can stop and
start you a little bit, is you make
a very clear contrast between wine and
oil and sustainable farming.
I forget the exact language there.
And one of the things that we can
do visually when we're delivering
a presentation is you always make wine and
olives in one place and
sustainable environment in another place.
And if you get used to that what you're
leaving, what you're putting behind,
is one direction,
what you're moving towards is another.
It gives you that visual of
the future that we're moving to and
what we're leaving behind.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Exactly, and
it also gives you something,
people are always saying, what do I
do with my hands when I'm up there?
I don't know what to do with my hands.
And that's one place where I can
easily use gestures, and it's natural.
It's comfortable in that.
Jenny?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> And they weren't.
It's just that we don't have to
make the [INAUDIBLE] wine or
the wine mill is still a big part
of our celebration and our life.
>> The problem is we could have
done this but it ruins the land.
So we do this, but
we still celebrate with it.
So someone else can ruin their
land elsewhere, but we're not.
I didn't quite follow along on your story.
And I guess if it was the loss of things
that sort of killed biodiversity,
then are you making the point that sort
of bringing in species that don't belong
somehere of life, is it literally?
>> No, the dichotomy was we initially were
going to do grapes and olive oil on all
the 800 acres, and instead we
decided to do biodiversity on it.
>> Because you care more about it
not because the grapes are going to.
>> Just because we care more about it.
>> I think that's the personal
dilemma that I didn't get.
That here is land that for
very important reasons is a bellwether for
lots of other issues and it is depth.
And we need a choice, we love wine and
oil with all of our hearts and
we made this very crazy choice
to give that up, our retirement,
to do biodiversity and
I've never been so happy.
>> And so what I had was we did
the unthinkable to our friends back
in California, expanded our restoration
to 800 acres not just 15 acres.
>> Too many numbers,
I don't know if [INAUDIBLE].
>> And we fundamentally changed
our passion from wine and
olive oil to investing in biodiversity.
>> So I would use like a ratio,
we quadrupled or we quintupled.
>> That's helpful, yeah,
make the statistics.
>> What do they mean for me?
>> Yeah.
>> But if you say we doubled down,
it's like, wow, okay, I get it.
>> That's a personal passion.
>> So good, okay.
I'm going to take two more points and
then we're going to let
him breathe a little bit.
Carol Robin always says
feedback is a gift,
you're getting lots of gifts right now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I can take it.
>> Amanda and then Ashley.
>> I just want to build a little
bit on Jenny's comment.
Jack, when I talked to you in the longer
version of your story, the way that you
talked about your original dreams of
retirement and traveling to Tuscan.
You don't ever say explicitly
we were dreaming of taking
our dream of retirement and
the cuisine which I love.
And maybe that happened in they purchased.
You don't see it explicitly in that,
I don't think for
us to understand, that's what they were
doing here, they were chasing this dream.
>> Which may help-
>> Of retirement,
of company retirement,
with delicious food and
they found themselves on this scorched
earth and this is the way it changed her.
So I think you could just more explicitly
say this is the stage we were at in our
life and it came to us.
The other thing that could be
really powerful in conclusion
would be to say my career path was X.
I was not a volunteer with the Nature
Conservancy, I was not a, you know.
>> What was your career path?
>> The joke is karmic kickback
because I'm a real estate developer.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, so funny.
Fantastic because we're
going to do [INAUDIBLE]-
>> That's brilliant.
>> All these people who are, at some stage
in their lives, going, I [INAUDIBLE] this.
You're open to it,
what's ahead for you, and
twist that you're planning on taking,
it's because you don't name it.
I just think if you had a place to
stick that in there [INAUDIBLE].
>> We had it in originally but
we cut it back because my wife said,
[INAUDIBLE] four minutes, let's at
least get this biodiversity piece.
It's not it's just about for anybody.
>> That comes through really loud and you
can still do it especially [INAUDIBLE].
4 minutes and 15 seconds?
>> Yeah, and so, what I'm hearing in that,
as you think through your own fray.
Like Jenny said earlier, I'm not sure
exactly what I'm going to talk about and
how this is going to fit in.
Hopefully, the conversation tonight helps
you kind of see that it's your journey.
And so with Bruce from the class of 55 or
Yuri from the class of 08 and everything
in between, everyone in between.
Your journey is really a part of what
this PNP 40th anniversary is about.
And so having all of these multiple paths
that end up making a difference and
making an impact.
That's meaty.
That's like our own little
Ted conference here.
Ashley, you had a comment,
I want to make sure I get it in.
>> The time has passed, it's okay.
>> Okay, okay, good.
>> I would say Jefferson more
impactful to me was listening to you,
that you made that choice.
>> No, I hear that.
>> Rather than, you don't have to
convince me biodiversity is important.
It's important to you, a smart guy, yeah.
>> Actually,
I'm going to disagree with this because
you missed a journalist called
the nut grab, which is the aha moment.
This is why [INAUDIBLE].
This is what it means.
because you're going to have
people who don't get it.
And if you lead them to
your moment of revelation,
they'll be able to catch the infection.
>> Right.
>> So that transition from what you
were going to do to what you were
doing is currently missing.
The nut of,
the heart of the Accresa Realty
is still [INAUDIBLE]
midnight.
>> Does that resonate for you?
>> Yes.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, and that's, yeah.
>> But if you could think about how you
could put that together you could say,
this is the bird that ruined my
dreams of a Tuscan retirement.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You're exactly right.
>> And so, and
then you start from there and
people are like, wait a minute,
what's going on there?
>> Yeah.
>> And then suddenly you've got
everybody hooked and.
>> This is the bird that
set my brain on flight.
>> Yeah.
>> Because this is really
extreme I'm not being all of.
>> Right.
>> Or there'll
be another change about
your dreams can host.
>> And that's a better dropping point too.
>> Yeah,
let's you parachute in at that moment.
Okay, so
I'm going to actually pause that and
at the very end let you come up for
one last moment.
But we're going to pick on Diego for
a while, okay?
So Diego, are you ready?
>> I came completely unprepared for
this, but, I'll give it a try.
And, you know,
since I violated five of the seven rules.
>> Thank you, yep, stay there.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Changing things on the fly.
Do you think we could put,
can I plug this in and try it?
>> Absolutely.
>> I for this presentation,
can I plug it in directly off of this?
>> My God, I thought it was a book.
>> [LAUGH]
>> That is so cool.
It depends on the dongle connection.
>> I got this, I got one of these.
Okay, so this is going to get off to
a rocky start because I changed my intro
since I was violating rule number,
I don't remember what, in the beginning,
so here it goes, I've never practiced
this but I'll give it a try.
>> So I'm going to pause you there.
>> Okay.
>> And-
>> All right.
>> Breakfast if out of the way?
We've all got it?
>> I've been introduced.
>> And first moment.
>> Okay.
A few years ago my oldest daughter
told me she hated math.
It was bad enough that this fell
into stereotypes for girls but
I also wondered if it was part of
a greater problem in teaching math and
sciences in the United States.
And it made me wonder why
were kids as engaged and
excited about math and
science as I was growing up?
>> [LAUGH]
>> All right,
well I didn't have this kids book.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It would have been really cool.
>> You know if anything, kids these days
should be more excited given the amazing
tools they have at their disposal.
So I started thinking about what I liked
as a child and what engaged me and
I remembered the high frame rate movies of
Doc Edgerton from MIT which stopped time.
And I remembers the Powers
of Ten video and
how it opened up the waters of
the universe in microscopic worlds in
a beautifully elegant and
concise ten minutes.
And then I went online and I found
these videos and I found other videos.
Like the video of the Tacoma Narrows,
that I remembered from Physics Class.
And then something surprising happened.
I started discovering a new generation
of these videos and stories out there.
And I realized the Internet was enabling
hundreds of thousands of people
passionate in math and science to
share their passion in innovative,
exciting and yes, quirky ways.
There are researchers in New Zealand
teaching computer science concepts without
computers.
There are PhD students in Detroit teaching
neuroscience with do-it-yourself kits.
There are contests encouraging PhD
students to dance their thesis.
And there were physics students
deconstructing the physical
impossibilities of My Little Pony.
And I start to collect these
stories in websites and
I realized I needed a place to store them.
So, I remembered another story that
grabbed my interest as a youth.
Schroedinger's cat.
It was a thought experiment that
Schroedinger used to explain the concept
of quantum entanglement.
And in the story, the cat was both
alive and dead at the same time.
So that gave me the idea for
a fun and engaging website name where
people could come together to
share their favorite math and
science stories, images,
videos, and websites.
So I set up this website and started
talking to educators and parents and
scientists in the broader community and
found an amazing desire and need for
simple tools to engage students.
And I found a lot of people surprised
that there was so much already out there.
I soon realized I had also stumbled
upon the perfect medium to
connect with this new
generation of learners.
And at zombie-cat.org, could leverage
this new explosion of social media tools.
So I incorporate zombie cat as a non
profit and I'm looking for help for
its launch and develop and upkeep.
You see, I don't know with
certainty if Hungarian dance is the best
way to teach sorting algorithms.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But after working on this for
the last nine months, I do know that
there's a pony in there somewhere.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Before we give you feedback,
the gift of feedback, can
you just go ahead and
set the script down for a minute.
>> Sure.
>> And give us the elevator pitch.
Give us the 30 second
summary of why this is
important to you, and don't worry
about the slides of the script.
Disconnect with the [INAUDIBLE]
why does this matter?
Diego?
>> Zombie Cat has become a window for
me into the broader challenges of math and
science teaching, but
also has created a bridge between
the two worlds of education.
And those rest of us that
are passionate about math and science.
There are about three or
four hundred thousand math and
science teachers in K-12 and
there are millions and
million of people who graduated and
work in math and science and
I found that this little snippets of
videos that are engaging and fun.
Create an intersection where
both worlds like to live and
both worlds can communicate.
And I find this as a neat little
beach head into the community.
>> Do you see the difference just
the eye contact the connectedness?
You know all this stuff really well and
your passion, this is palpable.
And that connection is very rich.
At this point I want to ask you questions.
I want to keep engaging and
want to learn more about it.
>> Uh-huh.
>> And so
the reason I wanted to do that is for all
of you that think the words are important,
but it's really
the connection with people.
That's ultimately what matters and
what you want to strive for, yes?
>> There's a genuine softness to
all your emotions that starts to
happen that's very engaging.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> I would agree, so both with this and
what he delivered at the beginning, what
was particularly effective about Diego?
What moved you the most, Al?
>> I loved the visuals.
>> So again, all our core key
cartoonist are updated there.
>> Yeah I know the episode
from WKRP in Cincinnati,
you didn't talk about that one but
I was like I know that one.
>> I like you're connection
to your daughter.
>> Yeah very well.
>> Yeah.
>> I was expecting her to resurface
somehwere.
>> Well I just added her right now so
[LAUGH] I'll work her in later.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I originally introduced myself.
>> Ernie has a good question,
do you actually have a daughter or
did you create her?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Does it matter?
>> Yeah, I would agree,
I like that connection.
>> You had a connection
with your daughter?
Any sort of a macro Girls that,
here's how the US stands globally.
And that felt really powerful.
These sort of things are meant
to protect the people.
>> Yeah.
>> So we're very particular and
very macro.
Yeah.
>> Good mix.
>> [INAUDIBLE] daughters.
She says that now she's quoting the blah,
blah, blah physics guy, or-
>> Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
And I love, when
you go back one slide, I think it
says insert call to action here.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well I didn't have slides when I showed
up here today,
I did those during the last presentation.
So yeah, call to action slide, yeah.
Hungarian dance.
>> I love that one.
>> They really do it.
>> And actually since he is still
very informative in terms of content.
I think telling him what
resonates is helpful.
Was there anything that didn't resonate?
Was there anything that lost you or
threw you that as he's deciding what
to include and what not to include?
Any thoughts on that for him?
>> Well, so the piece of, the stats on
the US and where we are, I get that.
What I didn't get was how this
organization will impact that.
>> Yeah,
well short answer is that four minutes.
But really this is about engaging.
I'm looking at a very small piece,
piece of the whole teaching equation,
which is how do I engage?
How do I get somebody excited and
then throw them over the fence?
I sometimes refer to the content
in Zombie Cat as a prop
room for teachers where I'm
not giving lesson plans.
I'm not telling you how
to teach something, but
I want you to give that hook.
It's like the jokes or
the courts he would use in his speech, but
in teaching, how would you engage?
If you think about the Tacoma Narrows
video, that was what a physics teacher,
that's the one thing they had to make
this stuff interesting to you, is, watch,
look at this bridge,
it fell, now listen to me.
You know and it was you know and
here's a video of it.
How often do you see a video of
a bridge start shaking and fall?
So it was, it's the idea that it's
not going to solve the problem.
I don't pretend it will.
But it's a small little nugget that starts
to put a wedge into the problem and
it works for many levels.
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
And another thing I noticed,
just naturally Diego,
you have a real gift for
language which is visual.
You mentioned mention a few minutes ago
when I said put the script down and
just tell us the story,
you talked about wanting to be a bridge.
And just now, when you were answering
Carol's question, you said,
I imagine that it's a prop room for
teachers.
Can you imagine a teacher if you had
a whole video library that you could pull
from to use in that regard.
And those naturally come to you so
embedding,
some of those in your presentation,
I think, would make it rich.
Now I know that you did your
slides while I was teaching.
>> [LAUGH]
>> There may be a useful video clip.
There may be 20 seconds-
>> No,
I would have liked to do this as a video
clip and things like the Powers of Ten
video, I mean, a lot of these videos
>> Even if it's just a snippet,
you get a lot more out them watching it.
And they're all videos, they're also
YouTube videos, which I wasn't going to
set up right now and kind of cross my
fingers I can get the web to work.
I would have to have that
all embedded deep in here.
But it would-
>> I think the idea would be to actually
almost have the presentation of the video
running behind the narrative and
hopefully sink it up a little bit and
get good enough at sinking it.
>> And I'm going to urge just
a couple of morsels that draw a sin,
they get up, they tease us that
make us want to go to your,
that make people write down the website
on their note so that they go visit it.
And probably a couple of places
where you go to a black screen and
it's just you in front of us.
Because I don't want you to diminish what
you bring to the room by too many visual
images behind you, so tease us
a little bit with it but then also.
Your passion as a parent and
as an educator really is rich.
>> People who don't even
believe I have children.
>> Yeah, well
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm not going to answer that question,
I'm just going to leave it out there.
>> But one thing that you did that was
risky but I think you is that you were
talking to us as someone with
inside knowledge and do you.
>> [INAUDIBLE] I don't know what that is,
but [INAUDIBLE] I have and
this [INAUDIBLE] and
speaking of the way that you speak
just above where your audience is and
they reach up to it.
>> And
I don't think I would've caught that, but
I also didn't know the complete analogy.
But it didn't bother me.
Because I trusted that he did.
>> I don't understand
>> [LAUGH]
>> I just think it's a cool story.
Go to zombiecat.org.
>> Yeah.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Great call to action,
thank you Diego awesome.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I loved that.
I loved it.
Remember last year or
two years ago at the beginning
of the CAT training and
I needed a big book like that.
>> That's right.
>> If I had only known I would've called
you.
>> There you go.
>> Okay, I need just a moment to get my
next video ready here.
What we
are going to do at this point
is I going to take questions.
We are at perfect time for
where I want to be and
what do we need to say, Amanda,
about follow up coaching?
>> We should have this link to the video
up by the end of this week and
at that point, I`m hoping I will be able
to send out some form of google document,
or some place where there`s a centralized
platform to express your interest in
having one on one
>> Did you like that?
And negotiating with
the coaches available as well,
so talk ready and
see the plans we are doing as well.
Tonight we won't worry about it,
it will just be something to watch for.
>> And I think what, I think as we look
at that part of the value is having
a couple other people in the room
that can provide that feedback.
And so we might look at designing
something that let's people come in in
small groups, twos or threes,
that also let's them network
a little more with alumni.
We hadn't thought that through exactly.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> As we look at that coaching
moment one of the beauties
I have here at the GSB.
I not only get to teach communications
classes, but I also lead a team
of 35 professional coaches that we
bring in to coach our MBA students.
To work with them on oral presentations.
The coaches who are here with us this
evening were hired originally as writing
coaches and are bridging into oral
presentation, we thought this was a great
way for them to get a sense of
what it looks like in the room.
But we also have a number of people
that coach teams here in the valley,
that do media training.
>> And so if it's not me working with you,
it'll be somebody else that I have vetted
in a small group where you'll actually get
to come in and try something, get some
feedback, but also have a professional
coach who's working with you on that.
And we're excited about putting
a schedule together that'll create that.
Before we go to the last video, questions
that you have on either the content that
I have delivered, the logistics of
the event as a part of homecoming.
Anything that we can answer
that's burning for you?
Gary?
>> Also you mentioned earlier, this
technique where you sort of go through
highs and lows, where you could be,
where things are.
>> I'm working [INAUDIBLE] as sort of
[INAUDIBLE] here's the world we see today.
Here's the [INAUDIBLE] how
that worked [INAUDIBLE]
>> Definitely that's
coming directly from
Nancy Duarte's work in Resonate.
And a lot of it is in
the language that you choose.
>> I'll give the example of the,
I have a dream speech as
he talks about the way things could be and
the way things are.
In an entrepreneurs pitch
part of the challenge for
an entrepreneur is to explain
that there is a pain point for
which you have the solution
which is your product.
>> And so I was working with
a group of entrepreneurs
in the bio-design class in the spring.
And they were solving sleep apnea.
And they had a device that was better
than going through surgery, which
is what people have to go through, if they
struggle with snoring and sleep apnea.
And they put a visual up,
they have a visual of what this.
Device that's currently on the market is
and it's like if you can imagine sleeping
with, if I can use this for a minute.
Sleeping with something like
this strapped to your forehead.
And you have to sleep with your back down.
And they showed a photo of what
that looked like, and then.
[LAUGH] I almost gave your
purse back to the wrong person.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And then they showed their device and
it was something that was
smaller than this and so
they showed the pain,
they showed the way things could be,
they showed the difficulty,
they showed the way they could be.
They had another slide later on where they
looked at the number of people who go
through surgery and the risk of surgery,
and that theirs was noninvasive.
Those are some of
the techniques that are there.
And I want to encourage you to look
through her book because she's really
good at illustrating that sort
of contrast back and forth.
Jack?
>> You're trying to get this,
do you have pitch?
Or do you have snippets you piece together
because you became more off record.
Everything got more comfortable and
relaxed.
In your mind do you have 15 little
modules you're playing with that
you're sort of moving around, or
do you really get your set 4 minute pitch
that you just polish, polish, polish?
Or all of the above?
>> It's a little bit of all the above,
what I would encourage is,
especially because the four
minutes is a hard and fast time.
When I have done speeches that
had to have that sharp of it,
is I get it to where I know the major
elements of what I'm going to say.
I don't memorize, I don't get from pure
manuscript which you're working off of.
In fact, if you look at my notes for
tonight.
Can I borrow?
He has got it right there.
My notes for tonight, the story that
I told, was just that set of bullets.
But I rehearsed enough in my head, I knew
it was right around a minute and half or
two minutes long.
I added few more details but
I wanted it to be under 3.
But I would read that over and
over and over again because muscle
memory kicks in and I remember that.
But if you go to memorization then
you're memorizing word for word and
when you forget, you're just nowhere.
And so
having the bullets is easier than that.
But because the four minutes is kind of
a hard and fast rule, I do think you have
to work to knowing what are the major
bits that I'm going to deliver.
Okay, yes Val?
>> Question, what's the deliverable?